So it's very important to feel
that whatever you're doing,
that's what you want to be doing.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here and today,
I want to talk about burnout.
Something that we all experience at
different times in learning languages.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a
podcast, please leave a review.
So to my mind, burnout is
associated with a number of things.
First of all with what I call
the doldrums, the plateau, when
you hit that point where you
feel you're not making progress.
So then we are discouraged.
You know, I've said before at the
early stage in learning a language, we
actually make quite a bit of progress.
It's a steep climb, but
we're actually climbing.
We can see where we were.
We look down, we see where
we were a month earlier.
We knew nothing.
Now we can say something,
we understand something.
So that's the sort of early call
it three to six months, the early
period in learning a new language.
But then we sort of come into a stage
where the words don't appear so often.
Uh, we've put in a lot of time,
we think we've put in a lot of
time and yet we have that feeling
that we're not getting any better.
Part of the problem is
we're too hard on ourselves.
And I think part of the problem, why
people experience burnout is they have
unrealistic expectations about how
quickly they can learn a language.
Manfred Spitzer, whom I often quote,
a German neuro scientist, said the
brain cannot do otherwise than learn.
The brain learns.
The brain is exposed to stimulus, stimuli,
and it forms patterns to deal with the
world that the brain is sort of confronted
with experiencing, but so he says the
brain cannot do otherwise than learn.
However, the brain learns slowly.
So we have to accept that as long
as we are exposing ourselves to
the language, reading, listening,
speaking, we are acquiring the
language, but we're doing it slowly.
And I think a lot of frustration
comes from unrealistic expectations.
Learning it slowly means it, the
language will continue to remain fuzzy.
Even something you listened to initially
three months ago and you're back, go
back to it now and you say, I should be
able to understand it very easily and
you go there and you can't understand it
easily, or you feel you should be able
to express yourself better and you can't.
So I think this, this burnout comes
from the feeling that you're doing
the same thing over and over again and
not achieving, achieving any results.
So I think the first thing you have
to do is to say let's be realistic
in what I'm going to achieve, and
let's try to enjoy what I'm doing.
Let's make sure that while you...
so to enjoy what you're doing A.
You gotta look for content
that's of interest.
So I put a lot of effort in my
language learning into looking for
things that are of interest to me.
So even if I feel that I'm not improving,
at least I'm not just going over the
same material over and over again.
At least I'm learning something
new or, you know, I, I found this,
these, uh, Jordanian cartoons that
are funny and, and, and give a bit of
a glimpse of Jordanian family life.
Uh, and I'll leave a link to them here,
but I'm finding it's it's enjoyable.
So whether I'm improving or not, I'm not
really sure but I am enjoying, you know,
reading those and listening to them.
So, uh, don't put unrealistic
expectations on yourself, find
ways to enjoy the process.
And also, and this is I think, a little
difficult today, you know, in the old days
we got a textbook and that's what we had.
And that's the only thing we used.
Now there's lots of options out there.
So it's very important to feel
that whatever you're doing,
that's what you want to be doing.
Don't be thinking about other things that
you would like to do, make sure that you
don't begrudge yourself the time you're
putting into the language, that's going
to make your attitude more positive.
So I enjoy what I'm doing.
I'm glad I'm doing it.
I may not really feel that
I'm progressing, but I have to
trust that my brain is gradually
getting used to the language.
I can assure you it's a long process.
Now, another thing that I think
is very important in order not
to get burned out is variety.
So variety comes in different...
in a variety of ways.
So the variety can be the
content you're listening to.
Vary it between advanced and beginner and
different subjects and things of interest.
Um, I find myself, for example, I say
I should do Persian cause I have a
tutor tonight, but I'm actually more
interested in doing the Arabic tonight.
Well, then do what you want to
do, make sure you're having fun.
So, but there's the variety there.
Um, again, the variety in terms
of the kinds of activities.
You can read, you can listen.
Uh, I'm also gonna do another
video where I talk about shadowing.
Uh, flashcards.
Variety is going to make you feel
less frustrated so you can do
one type of activity for a while
before you get totally tired of
it, go off and do something else.
And finally, if you're really
burned out, take some time off.
One of the interesting things about
language learning is when you back away
from it a lot of what you've been learning
continues to gestate in your brain.
I've called it this
period of benign neglect.
So don't feel that if you sort of stop
studying for a few weeks, you're going
to lose everything you've learned.
You won't.
In fact, when you pick it up again
very quickly you'll get back to where
you were and then you'll find that
you'll improve more quickly again.
So those are some of the strategies that I
would recommend in order to avoid burnout.
Thank you for listening.